le 11 janvier 2016 une embarcation
chargée de 1437 kg d'herbe de cannabis
est arraisonné au nord-est la guadeloupe
simard et d'angine saint-vincent thèses
sont interpellés il faut ni cependant
des informations concernant
l'organisateur poursuite des
investigations sur commission rogatoire
tout un dispositif de surveillance est
mise en place il permet de matérialiser
plusieurs débarquement d'herbe de
cannabis en guadeloupe en provenance de
saint vincent 4 135 kilos d'herbe sont
ainsi saisi le 11 octobre 2016 malgré
cette vague d'interpellations
l'organisation poursuit cette activité
le 18 octobre 2016 trois occupants d'un
véhicule transportant 333 kg d'herbe
sont interpellés en flagrant délit en
guadeloupe depuis lundi ils sont
auditionnés à la barre du tribunal
correctionnel de fort-de-france
mais ces nouvelles arrestations prouve
que l'activité est encore très intense
dans la zone caraïbes
nous sommes dans la zone caraïbes avec
des petits états indépendants des états
qui avec des fermiers avec des
fournisseurs qui vont venir vont
travailler fournit aux dons de la drogue
des stupéfiants aux antilles qui
constitue une espèce de plate forme de
vitrine et malheureusement on voit si le
résultat des prévenus de la guadeloupe
de la dominique et de saint vincent des
petites mains au chef de réseau des
hommes aux profils bien différents
vous avez des personnes qui sont là par
opportunité qui ne sont pas forcément
coutumière du fait qu'ils ont peut-être
céder par rapport à un besoin d'argent
qu'on est venu accoster du jour au
lendemain par exemple et qui ont dit oui
et qui pourtant n'avaient pas forcément
un passé judiciaire
et puis on a d'autres pour le coup qui
ont casier judiciaire plutôt nourris et
qui ne sont pas
personne novice en la matière donc elles
ne sont pas toutes à considérer de la
même manière vous avez des personnes par
opportunité qui ont été sollicités juste
pour conduire une voiture pour faire un
plein d'essence donc vraiment il
convient de s'attarder sur chaque
personne peut ne pas faire deux groupes
mais individualisé chaque situation
sur les 21 prévenus seule une dizaine
est présente à l'audience
les autres on bénéficie de contrôle
judiciaire ils n'ont pas répondu à leur
convocation
ce procès devrait durer en principe
jusqu'à vendredi
il risquait tout de même des peines de
deux à dix ans de prison